[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen we
are here today to celebrate independent
film but before we do I want everybody
to look at me don't look at the program
look right here
all right now spell independent is it de
NT or da NT now if you say a de NT
you're right if you say it be a NT your
development exec and we don't want you
here
[Applause]
I'd also like to clear something up
right now now I won't be doing any pulp
fiction humor today all right my name is
Sam not Jules I've done plenty of other
movies so how about quoting me some
lines from some of them for a change but
I was pretty jazzed about getting this
MC gig so I called my mom to tell her
about it now you know your parents are
always proud of you in what you do and
they don't necessarily believe what
Siskel and Ebert say so I'm telling my
mom about it and she says you know it's
cool she's proud of me I'm proud of you
Samuel you know the drill then I had to
spend another 20 minutes trying to
explain to her what it was and what
we're honoring because I tell you right
now
a lot of folks don't understand what an
independent film is like she asked me if
that big movie was getting any awards
and I told her no no talking animals got
nominated for this award show so I tried
giving her examples of what independent
film is I said it's something like
leaving Las Vegas safe dead man walking
she said so it's an award show for
depressing films I said no no no it's
it's independent film movies like the
addiction secret of roan inish Nadja
little Odessa and then she said so this
is an award show for movies I never
heard of which was kind of close so I'll
let it go with that but it illustrates a
point it's a different world
movies are being made everywhere at this
moment there are probably at least 20
indie films being shot all across the
country right now and their budgets are
probably less than it cost Miramax to
get this table way up front which says
that either budgets are dwindling or
that Harvey and Bob may be great at
their day job but they suck at
negotiating cheap seats
now movies are being made everywhere and
as audiences become more acclimated to
films that don't necessarily look
polished have no stars no inhibitions no
plot and no chance of recouping the
field opens up and amazing talents come
out of the woodwork from regions and
locales that are very far from Studio
City now more than ever film is
accessible to almost anyone almost
anybody can make a movie except that guy
who made clerks and you know the guy I'm
talking about he washes your windshield
if you stop at sunset and LaBrea nice
nice guy but no chance of ever working
in this town again
especially after his second movie
something about rats and a mall I don't
I don't know but he's a nice guy but
that's what we're honoring today the
strange the weird the eclectic division
area the new blood and those who've been
dancing to a different beat for years
independent voices ladies and gentlemen
those responsible for making the movies
that make us think a little deeper about
ourselves our world our lives and not
about how little you get for seven or
eight bucks nowadays
well now I'm going to bring someone else
up here who knows a little something
about the people who are talking about
her tireless efforts keep the IFP west
operating on a daily basis and in
exchange for her commitment throughout
the year we let her come up here and say
a few things before we start handing out
awards ladies and gentlemen the hardest
working woman and the independent field
outside of Lili Taylor Don Hudson
[Applause]
hi everybody
and IFP West our first mission is to
serve independent filmmakers to provide
them with the information and the
resources they need to get their work up
on the screen and our second is to
provide a sense of community for the
independent filmmakers especially here
in Hollywood and our third is to build
audiences for these films to bring
public attention to them for the films
that are smaller and stranger subversive
we hope more personal films now I'd like
to introduce the president of IFB West a
woman who's worked within and without
the studio's without losing her soul
welcome Barbara Boyle
I don't know it's something wild when we
have teleprompters I mean we may be
getting too much establishment I have to
do a couple thank-yous one particularly
to miss Don Hudson when I joined the
organization six years ago we were like
walking through the wilderness now under
dawn Hudson's guidance we are marching
down a broad path Thank You dawn I also
want to thank the three honorary
co-chairs Jodie Foster Laurence
Fishburne and John Travolta John
Travolta owes me one now I know why
Desdemona loved Othello so much he
looked like Laurence Fishburne and I
thank them very much for their devotion
to IFP Todd McCarthy wrote in variety
something I thought was very interesting
independent films are no longer
incidental independent films are about
something they are provocative and
interesting and for that we should all
in this room take a great deal of
pleasure and pride Winston Churchill
said I am easily satisfied by the very
best
ladies and gentlemen so am I miss Jodie
Foster
[Music]
Wow I get music - I never prepare
speeches but I can say one thing walking
out of this stage a lot has changed then
last year at the IFP for example we now
have teleprompters there is absolutely
nothing on them swear to god they got
the teleprompters because somebody was
supposed to have speeches and they
realized nobody could bother writing the
speeches so they're just sitting there
to attract you and to tell you how
important independent films really are
this year I imagine these changes are
about the amount of money that's coming
to the IFP and the amount of money
that's coming to the independent
industry for example a lot of actors are
out of work so they got the tallest ones
you know well Michael Crichton Liam
Neeson
John Lithgow they all came by you in
little Harlequin outfits - issue well
even though they weren't nominated I
mean you'll notice that your tables
there are these wonderful lazy susans
they decided I guess that you know now
that basically the studio is pretty much
financed these lunch and uh they may as
well not have to reach for damn thick
give us twenty more bucks the table and
we'll get you a lazy susan and everybody
said yes I am or serious note I think
there is something that has has quite
dramatically changed in the last year
this is my particular bandwagon right
now you'll be hearing lots of bandwagons
this afternoon
something that the IFP seems to excel in
my bandwagon is are just too many damn
movies made this year you may say but
hey isn't that a good thing isn't it
great that we have too many movies well
there were a lot of great movies there
are a lot of movies it stunk there were
a lot of independent movies there were a
lot of mainstream films distributed by
the majors there were a lot of movies
that tomorrow or the day after I will
not remember not one drop not one detail
there were a lot of movies that I'll
never forget and I wish I could there
are a lot of movies that
that were wonderful well-crafted
technically beautiful filled with heart
and longing and meaning that got pushed
out of the theaters about a week after
they came in once again too many damn
movies made I hope that we celebrate the
amount of independent films that have
reached the consciousness of America and
the world this year probably more than
any year that I can remember there's
that other race of course this week that
is peopled with lots of independence
coming in and saying somehow we figured
a way to get in I think what we're here
to celebrate today is provocative
excellent performances all in one year
that will move you and shape you and
change this industry forever so I pass
you on to the day and promise not to
talk too much
okay let's get this show on the road
before the tide rolls in our first two
categories are foreign film
I said foreign not boring I know same
difference
and the cinematography award which I
have nothing funny to say about but the
presenters are two very funny people who
I'm sure will have a lot to say you'll
be catching them both in the upcoming
release time to kill which has a small
cameo by me and he just completed his
directorial debut albino alligator which
was missing for just a little while but
he did finally recover his film and it's
now available in video cassette on 125th
Street and the homeboy cut and she just
finished directing her first short
making sandwich let's bring them up
Sandra Bullock and Kevin Spacey
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
anybody drunk yet that was funny
thank you well he said we were funny so
I figure we had to be where Santa and I
are very delighted to be here we in fact
we can't tell you how happy we are to be
here very happy I don't know why we
can't tell you but we can that we're
happy to be here in fact when the
Independent Spirit Awards called us and
asked us to be here we we said yes
immediately ambassadors for for film as
you would know maybe no okay well I mean
it's it's you know it's easy when when
they offer you you know good amount of
money to do just about anything what do
you mean they offered you a good amount
of money to do this what you're talking
about
oh yeah right that would be stupid
all right but not you got paid for this
is that you're saying what did you get
paid I mean I got you know I got it
gimme you know some money
it's you know it's it's a little bit you
know I tell me it's not you know it's
not huge but it's it's a nice you know
stipend as a stipend they paid you a
stipend to hand out this lawn ornament
oh that that's classy all right the
nominees but endlessly on Bravo later be
like a nightlight the nominees for Best
Cinematography are Elliot Davis for the
underneath Jim Deneau for Naja
the clan Quinn for leaving Las Vegas
Tom Richmond for little Odessa and
Newton Thomas Seagal for the usual
suspects and the Spirit Award goes to
[Applause]
decline Quinn leaving
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
well I don't have a lot to say just just
that I'm glad that there are stories
like leaving Las Vegas that are still
out there to be made and thank you Mike
and and Valdemar Annie and Nicholas
we have another category to announce but
I just want to say that despite
confusion about who's being paid and
who's not being paid for being here
today
I I Jenna and when they feel a lot of
warmth in this room and it's nice to be
taken for who you are and not always
identified with the parts you play
you you you know you have played some
pretty crafty roles this year haven't
you pretty out there kind of stuff that
you did this year is just really you
know out there yeah so what does that
mean nothing I'm just saying you know
like people often get roles you know
based on certain sides of you know their
personality you know directors can see
something in you that would make them
want to say here Kevin
play someone who would cut someone's
head off and put it in a box I mean it's
you know it's like you know it's great
that you allow that side to come out of
yourself so you drove a bus around in
circles all that summer what does that
say about you poster child for the RTD
alright the nominees for Best Foreign
Film are before the rain directed by
Milch oh man chef ski city of lost
children directed by mark karo and
jean-pierre janae exotica directed by
atom egoyan
I am Cuba directed by mikhail Cullotta
saw through the olive trees directed by
a bus Karos tommy award goes to before
the rain
[Applause]
[Music]
Catherina accepts this award on behalf
of the director milkman Chesky as the
producer I just like to thank a few
people took a lot of people to make this
film it's very difficult and for all
those people who are involved they all
took a risk and thank you for that I
just like to thank Gramercy Russell
Claudia and Steven thank you very much
I like to thank Polygram in France
British screen in particular Simon Perry
who else
oh god I've probably forgotten someone
but anyway on behalf of the producers
the cast and milk show thank you very
much for this award and I had you to
Katharina who's going to give a speech
by Milch oh thank you it's not really a
speech he just asked me to come up on
his behalf and accept the award and just
to thank everybody that voted for the
film for remembering it because it was
quite a while ago that it came out and
he's sorry he can't be here but thank
you from the bottom of his heart
thank you
you know the special distinction award
is given periodically to someone who
defines independence someone who does it
their way by any means necessary that
doesn't only describe our recipient but
also our presenter ladies and gentlemen
Peter Bogdanovich
[Applause]
thank you about 30 years ago I was a
young stage director who'd done some
second unit for Roger Corman and Roger
gave me a chance to make my own picture
my and I wrote a script with Polly Platt
and I'd known Sam fuller for about a
year and a half and I called him up I
went over to see him and I said and
Sammy was in his living room and his
Shack as he called it and he said tell
me the story kid so I sort of told him
the story scene-by-scene and when I got
halfway through I said when that and he
said why are you killing Carl off in the
middle of the picture kid I said well I
don't have him for two days Sam I I
can't he said never worry about anything
when you're writing a script never worry
about the time never worry about the
money right the way extrait the way you
want to kid worry about the money you
know all that stuff afterward so then
for the next three hours
Sammy walked up and down the living room
and rewrote the entire script I took a
lot of notes I went oh went back and and
typed it and that's what we shot and I
said to Sam Jesus Sam you you rewrote
the entire script I got to give you
credit for this no credit kid no credit
if you give me credit they'll think I
did everything you do it you take the
credit a couple of days later John
Ford's son Patrick Ford I told him the
story he said you just got the one of
the highest prayed one of the
highest-paid Hollywood script doctors
for nothing don't forget it I didn't so
I'm very happy to give an award to one
of the great independent Sam fuller he
he said to me one time so many things
over the years
that he's told me that I've remembered
one of the funniest things was I said to
him Sam you know there's a story and I
said do you ever do you ever make money
on pictures Sam I mean besides your
salary says very rarely very rarely
sometimes a picture makes so much money
they're embarrassed they give you some
of it
Sam has helped a lot of filmmakers
without credit over the years and I'm
not the only one believe me that you
heard of Sam has meant an awful lot to
me as a friend and as an inspiration as
he has to so many people who never met
him he is independent when it said
written directed produced by Samuel
fuller you knew who would made this
picture that's one of the things we
independent that independent has always
stood for and that's what Sam stands for
I don't think there's a picture I've
done that I haven't thought of something
he told me during the time I was making
it but the thing I remember on every
picture I've done is something he said
to me kid remember save your money for
the finish
so now thank you Sam for everything
typewriter was it
typewriter rifle movie camera it's the
first time you said that head tells her
story Sam once said to me he said when
you start your script if the first scene
doesn't give you a hard-on throw the
goddamn thing away
[Music]
such a sour note you're way off key
Samuel fuller
[Music]
sometimes we like to get presenters up
here that have something in common like
they've worked together or they're in
the same field and in keeping with that
tradition we tried to find the
connection between our next two
presenters people who were romantically
attached to Jeff Goldblum didn't work
for him and people who are more lucky
lucky even talented didn't work for her
finally we found the connection people
who work with Miramax and live to tell
about it I have that in common with him
to her on the upcoming citizen Ruth and
him on the upcoming chasing Amy
ladies and gentlemen Laura Dern and
Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
you know they asked they asked us to
come up and do the presentation and
stuff and I'm you know it's great to be
involved in the independent film and
stuff but I've really wanted to use this
chiefly why I did it was just to choose
this public forum for the industry to uh
to publicly apologize for Mallrats I
I just don't know what I was thinking on
a more positive note on a more
celebratory note this must be exciting
for you though must be cool huh y-you
were you were up for both the awards
we're presenting today last year aren't
you right so anyway the nominees for
best I don't know say something about
that er I don't think so so the nominees
for the best of features you know I mean
just to say what it feels like you know
how exciting it is to win an Independent
Spirit Award no honest choice why do you
wrong because I didn't win spanking the
monkey one Pope Awards wow man these
bastards on me ramblin rose who
nominated in every category
really all right so pushing on then yeah
the nominees for Best first screenplay
are kids
written by Harmony Korine little Odessa
written by James gray postcards from
America written by Steve McClean river
of grass written by Kelly Rijkaard
and smoke written by Paul Auster
and the spirit award goes to Sam fuller
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Paul Auster smoked heaven and Sam I'm
thrilled to accept this award on behalf
of Paul he wasn't able to be here
tonight but he wanted me to thank Peter
Newman his director Wayne Wang and
Harvey and Bob Weinstein thank you
see if we can get this one right the
nominees for best for his feature are
the brothers McMullen written by Edward
Burns kids directed by Larry Clark
[Music]
little Odessa directed by James Gray
picture bride directed by kayo hata and
river of grass directed by Kelly
Rijkaard Spirit Award goes to the
Brothers of Mon
[Music]
[Applause]
Eddie couldn't be here tonight today
actually he's finishing up on his next
film but on his behalf I just wanted to
thank the IFP West need a couple other
people he wanted to thank he wanted to
thank his cast and crew for doing
everything they did on this film he
wanted to thank Tom Rothman and most of
all he wanted to thank everyone that saw
the film thanks a lot
[Applause]
the swatch someone to watch award ladies
and gentlemen is given to an indie
filmmaker who our jury designates as an
up-and-comer that you might not have
heard of yet but probably will in the
near future to present this award is a
fine gentleman a great actor and a good
friend I Love You Man
I work with the man you might remember a
little movie called Amos and Andrew
okay how about kiss of death okay he's
not only received the nomination for
Best Actor here today but for that
alternative award show whatever it's
called for his performance in leaving
Las Vegas in which he plays a man who's
an even bigger nuisance in public
restaurants than Harvey Weinstein
give it up for Nicholas Cage
[Applause]
[Music]
last year the IFP West and swatch teamed
up to create these someone to watch
award which honors independent
filmmakers of exceptional talent and
unique vision who deserve much wider
recognition the someone to watch award
is an unrestricted twenty thousand
dollar grant which which the recipient
may use to pay off labs pay the rent
while writing the next script or even
shoot a new film in a word this award
provides freedom this year the award
selection committee chose five finalists
from over 90 nominations submitted from
around the country although their
creations are diverse they are alike in
their artistic spirit and in their
determination to create films however
slowly and painfully independently these
are five filmmakers to watch and five
names to remember the finalists for the
1996 someone to watch award are Tim
McCann director of desolation angels
Jennifer Montgomery director of art for
teachers of children Christopher mooch
director of color of a brisk and leaping
day
kelly reich art director of river of
grass and revile szalinski director of
fun this year's Award recipient received
critical acclaim and won several awards
for his 1991 feature the hours and times
he wrote directed produced financed out
of pocket cast shot and edited the film
photography on the hours and times
covered a period of eight days primarily
in a Barcelona hotel room with the crew
of two and himself and a camera
assistant who he met while picking up
his camera his latest film color of a
brisk and leaping day took him four
years to complete from script to screen
and we hope this award will make a
difference in his career just as we know
that he will make a difference in
American cinema I am honored to announce
the winner of the 1996 swatched someone
to watch award christopher munch
[Applause]
[Music]
it's really beautiful
I really feel very honored to be the
recipient of this award although I have
to say I don't feel that I deserve it
any more than any of the other
filmmakers who were just mentioned who
were the finalists who are all really
outstanding so and I'm very very moved
thank you and I think it's really a
wonderful award that the swatch company
is giving because it's unique in the
film world and I think for people who
are working sort of in less familiar
forums and doing more challenging work
it's a very meaningful acknowledgement
of that so it's bill and Denise and
everybody at swatched thank you so much
and I hope it's in some way on some
level of validation of a certain type of
arthouse independent cinema that has
kind of been waning in recent years but
which I hope will continue to thrive and
so for all the filmmakers who are
working with less familiar forums and
and and doing more challenging work I
encourage them to persevere so thanks
asking for the check he almost gave it
to me I'm really excited because I just
got some excellent news from my agent
I'm going to be doing a guest shot on
the season ender of friends
swear to God swear to God I play Jews
yeah I know what I said but come on it's
France anyway Jules is on his Odyssey
and he goes into Central Park with a
semi-automatic and opens fire on the
friends
opens fire on the friends because he
realizes they represent the inequities
of the selfish and the tyranny of evil
men but don't worry don't worry they're
so pumped full of caffeine they don't
even realize it dead and then Rachel and
Ross sleep together our next two
presenters are also friends because they
work together in last year's bullets
over Broadway that was a badass segue
wasn't it rude
he can be seen in the just-released
Diabolique Mulholland falls and faithful
and she's in the Sundance hid bound give
it up for a chance momentary and miss
Jennifer Tilly
[Applause]
[Music]
hello Chaz and I are really happy to be
here supporting the independent film
industry an independent film the actors
are allowed to take chances sometimes in
those chances magic happens we are very
proud to celebrate the magic that these
10 actors have brought to the screen the
nominees for the best supporting male
are Benicio del Toro for the usual
suspects
James lagron for the vegan oblivion
David Morse for the crossing guard
max per lick for Georgia
Harold Perrineau for smoke
and the Spirit Award goes to Vinicio del
Toro for the usual
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you I like to thank Bryan Singer
the director and Chris McQuarrie the
writer and the cast Chaz Kevin Spacey
Gabriel Byrne Stephen Baldwin kevin
Pollak
Chaz Palminteri Pete Postlethwaite and
the DP Tom Siegel well so I got some
other people here to think don't I'm
Eileen Felmy for giving me the script
Rick yarn and Ken Koken oh thank you
[Applause]
every time I see him I go into that
character III when he we were on the set
when he started doing it we all looked
around to each other and said what is he
saying and we couldn't believe it and I
really have to applaud him because it
was such a risk that he was taken that's
what I was talking about when I said
magic and he just brought it there and
he just made magic be really good no I
always wanted to meet him because I love
inarticulate men
all right and now to the ladies the
nominees for Best Supporting female are
Jennifer Lopez for MILF Amelia
Vanessa Redgrave for little Odessa
Chloe 78 for kids
Sylla Weston for dead man walking
mara Winningham for Georgia
and the Spirit Award goes to Maura
Winningham for Georgia
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Jennifer Jason Leigh you're the
reason I'm up here you're the heart and
the soul of Georgia and I love that I'm
not separated from you today I need to
be with you I'm honored to have backed
you up and to everyone from the Georgia
film core that I owe my thanks I give my
love and to everyone that I love my
family friends I give my thanks
[Music]
I gotta tell you the next award is my
favorite just because it's fun to say
the findi ladies and gentlemen the findi
is given to a person or organization
that can only be described as a friend
of film findi last year it went to
Goldwyn so this year's recipient should
be a little worried if you know what I'm
saying to present this award we got a
friend of the recipients to come up here
and say some nice stuff about them so
put your hands together for mr. Saul
Zaentz
[Music]
[Applause]
I had to make some notes because next
week Tuesday afternoon I become senile
it's really an honor and a great
pleasure to present awards to people
like Marci Michael and Tom who worked
for film with film and love film we have
never made a deal with them I have never
been able to make a deal with them and
that hasn't changed our relationship of
friendship much our picture we just did
they dropped out of the race when the
budget reached 28 million dollars they
said something like the yen exchange
with the dollar financial restrictions
and all of that and then they called me
into the office and said things like
they love the script they love the
casting they love the actors and they
liked me a little bit too but they
weren't gonna go with dollar over 28
million so we went on and they
introduced me to Miramax they send me
down the street and were able to make a
deal with them what I'm really what I
really want to say is Tom Marcy and
Michael possess everything that
independence independent filmmakers have
to have you have to have a passion for
films you have to have a desire to learn
everything about making a film which not
only includes your your job but whatever
one else does on a film and then you
have to have the guts to break through
that solidified wall of crap that's
placed around every one of us because
whatever you do today doesn't count
tomorrow unless you got Redford and
Pfeiffer in the picture and you can make
it at a certain price but you I have
nothing but the highest admiration for
all of you who worked their ass off
collective asses off in making pictures
and we're a Tom we're Marcy and Mike
everyone gets one I'm the designated
speaker because I am the loudest of the
three of us we like to thanks all
especially for presenting this to us
Saul Zaentz is relentless drive for a
high quality
he always achieves in his work in his
friendship and generosity to us and
others in the independent film world
make it doubly meaningful for us to
receive this from him many years ago in
1984 when we were Orion classics we
received a very first Fendi Award the
event occurred on a Sunday afternoon at
the Wilshire able theater there were
about 60 people in the audience half
asleep wondering what this independent
film business was about there was not
one major independent filmmakers star
agent or critic Preta present now we
were up here and see what's before us
Wow the independent film community is
more vibrant now than we think the
studio system is the studios are now
looking to a lot of people in this room
for their inspiration for new ideas
writers casting directors new
distribution strategies this would not
have occurred without the IFP the IFP
both on the west coast and the East
Coast has made this community a family
with a unified purpose we are grateful
to the IFP for this award but mainly for
its existence its steadfastness and
serving the independent filmmaker which
is ultimately what Sony Pictures
Classics is all about on behalf of Marcy
and Tom and myself we thank you so much
okay we're at that point in the day
where we give away the Best Screenplay
and Best Debut performance Awards I know
it's a weird pairing of categories but
you know I don't program to mess I'm
just a glue that holds it together now I
know you're all sitting there asking
yourselves where's young Hollywood today
where are the Eddie furlong the Alesha
wits funny you should ask
he's on screens now and before and after
and she's a regular on the CBS hit Sybil
ladies and gentlemen Eddie furlong and
Alicia I want to tell a joke these two
horses come walking into a bar right
bartender takes one look at him he says
hey fellas what's with the long faces
you got a long faces right what's with
the long faces
right the nominees for Best Screenplay
leaving Las Vegas written by Mike Biggs
living in Oblivion written by Tom
DiCillo safe written by Todd Haynes
the secret of roan inish written by John
Sayles
the usual suspects written by
Christopher McQuarrie award goes to
[Applause]
Christopher McQuarrie for the usual
suspects
Russell Schwartz has just informed me
that by winning this I'm screwed on
Monday I honestly I wouldn't have it any
other way if I had the choice I've
completely forgotten everything I'm
going to say just to be included in this
sort of company I keep is very
intimidating and to be chosen like this
is a true badge of honor I I look at
independent film and what it represents
and especially the suffering and I can
honestly say that out of all the people
nominated it probably everybody in this
room I have suffered less than anyone
the person that really suffered in my
place is Bryan Singer who was out here
who has been out here ten years to my
view and made it possible for me to come
out and start making my first feature
film three months after I arrived so I
at least the wings on this thing belong
to Bryan and I also want to thank the
entire cast for being so respectful and
so completely careful with all of the
language with glaring exception to
Benicio del Toro I I give Benicio all
the credit for that performance and he's
always telling me stop it man if I suck
they can blame you but thank you very
much this is indeed a great honor thank
you
why the long faces right just read
alright fun alrighty the nominees for
Best Debut performance are Jason Andrews
for Rhythm Thief Lisa Bowman for river
of grass
Gabriel Casillas for a New Jersey drive
Rose McGowan for doomed generation and
Justin Pierce for kids and the Spirit
Award goes to Justin Pierce for kids
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm supposed to say something right now
thank you I'd like to thank my mom first
obviously definitely my father secondly
Larry Clark thirdly poverty Kareem for
writing this for this award really goes
to obviously I wouldn't have said
nothing that he didn't write so now it's
Howard Stern at all I like to take my
mom's my daddy locked up in uh LA and I
also like to take my family that's
basically it
peace thank you
so why the long faces
all right okay four more and we're out
of here all right
to hand out Best Actor Award ironically
enough we have two of the businesses
best actresses alfre woodard who will be
appearing this fall and follow me home
and Mary McConnell who recently starred
in the upcoming
mariette in ecstasy and Independence Day
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon Mary and I are very
excited to be here to present this
category at the Independent Spirit
Awards and no jokes for us we are
probably the only two presenters that
walk away from here today with our
dignity intact
amen amen I'll free yep okay that's
great
good good for you girl good for you dawn
go Mary go Mary
I'll go Mary give the statue to the boys
baby know who are the Mary the nominees
for Best Actor are Nicolas Cage for
leaving Las Vegas
Sean Penn
yet man walking
Tim Roth for little Odessa
Jimmy Smits for me Familia
and Kevin Spacey for swimming with
sharks
and the winner is showing pen for dead
man walking
[Applause]
[Music]
I guess this means you tolerate me you
really tolerate them and I am wondering
if Jack Nicholson is black so I this is
really really nice I love this movie
very much
and I thank the people that were
courageous enough to pay to make it
Gramercy and working title of course
sister Helen Prejean wrote the book
Susan Sarandon
and of course Tim Robbins
and since since the movie does sort of
hedge on some political things I I just
want to sum that up by saying that in
the in the name of my little angels
Dylan and hopper and in the words of my
bad guy killing us wrong whether it's
you may or our government
thank you very much
[Music]
I guess I won't be telling him which way
to go along with Mary was going to
present something else the Award for
Best Actress is for along with me wait a
minute
thank you along with Mary who's going to
present something else here to present
the Award for Best Actress is someone
who got to live in Jurassic Park and who
just directed the short film little
surprises which is nominated for the
alternative award and is also starring
with Mary in the upcoming Independence
Day ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Jeff Goldblum
[Applause]
[Music]
and again Mary McDonald I I promise I
won't dance I promise
I missed that you danced before well
Alfred I I don't know we got carried
away we haven't been together in a while
what you do passion fish in Grand Canyon
oh yeah and Grand Canyon so good you
were so wonderful Jeff thank you well I
like your work to what oh you do yes I
do
we've never met before it's true we've
never met but we did a movie at this if
we did this Independence Day that's that
where that's out this summer yes bad
aliens yeah we're in the same movie we
never met Wow well it's a real honor
real honor the honor is mine oh thank
you so much okay
the nominees for best female lead uh uh
Jennifer Jason Leigh for Georgia
and a lien allowance infer Nadja
Julianne Moore for sale
and elisabeth shue for leaving las vegas
lili taylor for the addiction
and the spirit award goes to elisabeth
shue leaving Las Vegas
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much I really didn't want
to have to get up here um uh uh it's a
real honor just to be included among
these group of actresses and I'd like to
especially thank Jennifer Jason Leigh
for her incredible inspiration because
when I first got this part the first
movie that I watched was last exit to
Brooklyn and she really taught me my
characters need to be loved and I really
thank you for that
[Music]
and I'd like to thank Mike Figgis for
rescuing me and for Nicolas Cage for
being in this movie with me
and for our producers and he steward and
Lila and page and and Stewart thank you
really without independent films I'd be
nowhere and I would have never gotten
this chance so thank you for honoring
them means a lot to me
all right and then their work to the
best director award ladies and gentlemen
is something we take very seriously at
the spirits and to illustrate just how
seriously we take it we're bringing out
some seriously talented legends what
more can I say about them miss Jenna
Rowland's and the man who won the
alternative Award for Best Supporting
Actor last year mister mister
mmm-hmm I can do it I can do it
there's Dena Rowland's and mr. Martin
Landau
[Applause]
[Music]
well I know a few things about directors
but but the one thing that I really know
is that they all have vision and they
all have passion and they all have the
responsibility of the picture from
beginning to end they spend every waking
hour with that picture they put it to
bed like a child when it's done and then
they face the critics when the film
comes out into that cruel cruel harsh
world for that all of them ought to get
an award but unfortunately we're only
giving one out today just one the
nominees for Best Director are Michael
elmerita
for Nadja
[Music]
Mike Figgis for leaving Las Vegas
bulu gross part for Georgia
Todd Haynes were sick
John Sayles for the secret of wrong
inish
and the spirit award goes to Jenny you
do the honors
Mike Figgis we're leaving Las Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
a couple of years ago I played a very
mean trick on an actor we were shooting
a reshoot of a reshoot and I was having
some problems and the actor wanted to go
home and get on a plane and I needed
another couple of hours so I had a flash
of inspiration and I looked at the
action I said I smell Oscar and the
actor looked at me and said do you mean
that and I said yes I do well I didn't
tell that actor was that my
mother-in-law has a very oversexed
poodle called Oscar so every time
anybody asked me what I think about the
Oscars I can't get Oscar out of my mind
it's just something I'm stuck with when
I was working with Nick
one day I have the impulse to say I
smell spirit but he would have said I
swear Mike I haven't touched a drop
which is true I'm very very proud to
have this award I thank you all very
much for it
by making the film the way we made it I
threw myself into the low-budget hell I
turned down the James Bond movie to do
leaving Las Vegas which which was proud
to do
but seemed like a financial suicide at
the time it's very very difficult I'm
trying to set up another film now and
I'm trying to continue the spirit of
filmmaking that we started with leaving
Las Vegas and I it's it's not impossible
but it's not easy and there are a number
of factors that make it really really
difficult I'd love to think that it was
possible for young enthusiastic talented
filmmakers just to do what Truffaut and
got out and everybody did which is just
borrow steal rent a 16-millimeter camera
a hi-8 camera whatever it is and go out
and make a film but there are so many
restrictive situations within the
american film community which are not
there for bad reasons the unions exist
for all the best reasons in the world
and I grew up in Britain and I'm a firm
believer of of the right of everybody to
have the protection that they need but I
just wish that we could cut some slack
and that deals were easier to make and
that one could hold budgets down and
make films half the time that we tend to
make them and maintain the kind of
energy that I think resulted in good
filmmaking
and finally I having somebody at a
sermon the other day made a very good
statement which is this may be the most
important point in your life but it's
probably the dullest and least important
moment in everybody else's life right
now so keep it short so I will but
sincerely I would like to I can't leave
this stand without thanking a number of
people and forgetting an equal a number
of people just through the kind of white
blank that comes down like to thank my
production designer Valdemar kalinosky
who's worked on every film I've made
here I'd like to thank my friend Annie
Stuart for sticking through me with me
through all kinds of problems and then
co-producing this film with Lila cos
Aires and Jean cáceres
again the irony was this is a film I
couldn't finance here which is you know
makes me sad I love working here but
every single independent and every
single minor division of every major
turned to film down at three and a half
million dollars with Nic Cage and
Elisabeth Shue and me they didn't think
that was a viable package and so a
special thanks to the French and Lila
cos Ayers and John Cazale and Lumiere
pictures
when the film was finally edited and
finished I then did the rounds again and
tried to get distribution for the film
and the first people to see the film and
the only people to make an offer for
distribution where mgm/ua and I have to
say with absolute honesty and no
that the job that they did was
quite superb the patience that they had
the platform release and the films been
out there for a long long time slowly
gaining cinemas and now slowly losing
them but they did an incredible job and
I really would like to thank them for
that
and Jim and I'm gonna leave but I have
to thank Declan Quinn for his amazing
cinematography and art on cameras for
their beautiful camera and my very
special agent Robert Newman who raised
the finance for the film and and finally
and last but definitely not least I'd
like to thank Nicolas Cage and Elisabeth
Shue for really the best working
experience I've ever had in my life with
two actors thank you very much
[Music]
here that
that's the melodic tinkling of a
thousand people reaching for their car
keys which can only mean one thing it's
time for best feature ladies and
gentlemen to present the Spirit Award
for best feature
Nicole Kidman and this year's honorary
co-chair mr. Laurence Fishburne
[Applause]
[Music]
Jax ladies and gentlemen particularly
those of you outside the tent this is
samuel l.jackson
I am Laurence Fishburne please do not
get us confused with each other again
what I was tired I you know I got no
choice
shall we start yeah the nominees for the
best feature are the addiction produced
by Dennis Hahn and Fernando Silesia
leaving Las Vegas produced by Laila
cases and Annie's chouet living in
Oblivion produced by Michael Griffiths
and Marcus fish eating
safe produced by Christine vashaun and
Lauren Val Venis the secret of roan
inish produced by Sarah green and Maggie
Renzi award goes to leaving Las Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
okay anyway I think I should thank the
studios because they all pass in the
project oh I got it I fell in love with
and I got a chance to finance and
produce with Annie and okay we like to
thank of course mighty uses his films
absolutely
and Elizabeth that was like a miracle
she's incredible and Nikolas into Declan
Declan and John Smith that did a
fantastic job editing the film and
United Artists and absolutely
thank you so much thank you
all right I can't thank you enough for
having me I just want to say I love you
man
and congratulations to all the nominees
and all winners and all of you for
sitting through the two hours plus hours
of this show and if we had any more of
those trophies left I'd give you all but
there are no more which only means one
thing this show is over
hello good afternoon
[Applause]